We've seen that if we have a constant function like y equals 1 it looks like
this just a straight horizontal line. Now if we increase the degree of this by
one, straighten out this is a zeroth degree polynomial, if we up it by one we
get something like y equals x which takes that horizontal line and just rotates
it. Now it has a nonzero slope. Now if we increase the power by one more we get
a parabola. A quadratic function. And we know if we increase it by one more
once again, we get this really cool cubic function. Now, you just saw your
first higher order polynomial, in the last quiz. And I think that, we should
focus on one of these in particular for right now. Let's look at the graph of y
equals x to the 5th minus x. Let's just look at the overall appearance of this
function. And then build up some information about polynomial functions in
general based on that. We saw a big picture of this graph earlier showing
pretty big range on the y axis in a pretty big part of the domain on the x. But
now I've zoomed into the middle where some of the most interesting stuff is
happening. Remember that the ends of the graph, this way and this way, are just
sort of continuing on for a long time in the same direction. So it seems like
all the changes are happening in here. Because this is the only area where
things are changing, we can split the domain into sections based on what's
happening in here. Now I see one change happening right around here. And
another change happening right around here. So with these lines I have
effectively divided the domain into three chunks. Three different intervals.
Now let's label these intervals interval one, interval two, and interval three.
It also seems like there are two special points. These two right here. I'll
color them in this bright blue color and label them points A and B. These are
of course the points where these lines separating the parts the domain from one
another intersect the graph of our function. So let's talk about what the graph
looks like within each of these intervals and why these two points are special.
Now first of all, can you tell me in which of these intervals the graph is
increasing? And which of them the graph is decreasing. And second which of
these two points is a relative maximum and which one is a relative minimum?